a California couple is hospitalized this
morning after being airlifted out of
woods where they'd been stranded for
more than a week the survival of hikers
e'en Arwen and Carroll cap our ski is
being called a miracle in part due to
their age both are in their 70s they
were found in Marin County
northwest of San Francisco Jamie yuccas
reports on how they made it out more
than a hundred first responders and
volunteers spent days combing through
thick terrain and woods searching for
Carroll kovarsky and her husband Ian
Arwen as hope diminished the search
turned into a recovery effort but then
nearly eight days after the couple first
vanished signs of life about halfway up
we hear voices then they start yelling
help we look at each other and like
that's them rescuers had a crawl and
break through thick brush in order to
reach the couple they were like thank
God you found us we're so happy the
couple from Palo Alto had gone on a hike
on Valentine's Day near the vacation
rental they went without their cell
phones food or water they got lost and
survived by drinking from a puddle
Irwin who's 72 in Kapowski who's 77 were
airlifted suffering from hypothermia but
okay temperatures had dropped into the
low 30s at night kovarsky is a prominent
linguist and the author of several books
while Arwen a chemist is a leading
Parkinson's disease researcher family
members say they're in good spirits
speaking with the family this is a
miracle for CBS this morning I'm Jamie
yuccas